Film Courage: In a pitch meeting, what are
the stakes for the writer and the executive?
Carole Kirschner: Well for the writer the
stakes are kind of obvious. It’s this is
either going to launch or advance my career.
Or, this is something I love so much I can’t
wait to do this. I want them to buy it so
that I can do it. And as a side note, if you
love it that much, write it yourself. But
that’s a side topic…So what is at stake
for the writer is, will this help my career?
Now that is the same thing that is at stake
for the executive, because the executive is
dying to find a great project that is going
to make them look good….because in Hollywood
everybody wants to look good. It’s about
looking good. So if you’re picking the winning
horse you are looking good. The executive
you are pitching it to most likely has to
go pitch it to their boss. So you want to
make sure you give the person you are pitching
to a logline that they can then take to their
boss and as an easy way to pitch your project
because they become your advocate and they
want to look good in front of the boss. So
they are hoping that your pitch is going to
make them look good. Film Courage: O.k. So
let’s say in this hypothetical meeting they
don’t want the script that you’re pitching
but they like you, there is a sensibility
about you. They like your style but your foot
is kind of in the door, but not totally. They
say “Hey, this isn’t what we’re looking
for….” What would normally be said and
done in this situation? Carole Kirschner:
What would normally be said is “Come back
with other ideas.” So you would come in
and pitch other ideas. Or they might say if
they really like you “We have a project
that we think you’d be great for…” So
they’re pitching you a project. If they
really liked you or if they didn’t respond
or want to use that material, but they wanted
to be in business with you, they would be
in business with you. Film Courage: So if
they say come back to us with something else.
You come back home, put your keys down after
the meeting, how soon are you working on this
next thing, knowing that there is a person
who may choose something I do and has the
ability to launch me? How fast am I getting
this script to this person? How urgently am
I contacting them? Carole Kirschner: That
is a great question. You want to stay on their
radar, that is really important. You don’t
want six months to go by. But you want to
be prepared for the pitch, so I would say
four weeks. I would say a month to 6 weeks
at the outset. I would just stay in touch
and say I’m excited and I’m working on
this. Or have your representation say I only
wanted to come back to you with stuff that
is fully formed or that is ready to pitch.
Now if they say “Just come back with some
ideas,” I wouldn’t wait more than two
or three weeks. I would come back. I would
use all of your time, all of your energy,
all of your talent to come up with great ideas
that have a beginning, middle and an end and
compelling characters that you can talk about.
Film Courage: How much is too eager, though?
Because you know, someone could be living
in 100-degree weather in the San Fernando
Valley with no air conditioning and they came
out to Los Angeles so excited and they feel
like this is their chance! But the mere fact
that they are so, so ready, repels…Carole
Kirschner: Yes! You don’t want to be desperate.
People smell desperation. So if you came back
the next day, that would be too soon. I wouldn’t
even do it the next week. I would wait a minimum
of two weeks. Because if you come back the
next day then they will think that you didn’t
put time into it. On the other hand, in this
business the way it works is you wait, you
wait, you wait and then you get a call “We
need it now! We want you to come in tomorrow.”
That actually happens. And you have to be
prepared for that because suddenly something
shifted on the other side of the table and
they need you and they need it right away
so be prepared to do that. But don’t be
the person who says “I can come back in
tomorrow?” Film Courage: Sounds like three
weeks is a safe zone. I like that. Carole
Kirschner: It is…..get the meeting on the
books though…. Film Courage: Are you doing
this right away while you are there? Carole
Kirschner: No, no. That would be in the next
couple of days, you would say “I’m going
to be ready to come back in. I’ll let you
know. It will probably be within three weeks.
Should I make the appointment now or later?”
and you talk to their assistant. QUESTION:
Anything you can add about the follow-up pitch
meeting?